c'était pas clair qu'il fallait le
rembourser Vincent des biens a reçu il y
a quelques jours une lettre de Service
Canada il fait partie des centaines de
milliers de Canadiens qui doivent
rembourser en totalité ou en partie leur
premier versement de PC
c'est sûr que les gens auraient faites
plus attention à ces montants là aussi
au printemps 2020 vous avez reçu un
paiement initial de la piscine de 2000
dollars il s'agissait d'une avance de 4
semaines pour vous verser de l'argent le
plus rapidement possible est-il écrit
dans sa lettre deux ans plus tard
Vincent Desbiens comprend que ce premier
versement était un prêt c'est vraiment
beaucoup le comme ça surtout là c'est
ainsi ou est-ce que on sait avec
l'inflation c'est pas facile non plus
pour pour se loger tout ça puis là à la
veille des vacances recevoir une lettre
comme ça c'est jamais bien le fun dans
un communiqué de presse passé sous le
radar en novembre dernier Service Canada
écrivait que les Canadiens qui ont fait
une demande de PC eu avant le 14 juin
2020 serait contacté pour les informer
de leur dette ce toutefois qui ont reçu
de la PCE tout l'été ont pu commencer à
rembourser le paiement anticipé à même
leur cotisations les parties
d'opposition accusent le gouvernement
d'avoir manqué de transparence et de
clarté jamais dans les messages dans les
publicités qu'on a entendu c'était aller
chercher votre prêt de PCU le
gouvernement est là pour vous aider et
un bon côté c'est que ça a été fait vite
mais le le mauvais côté c'est que ça a
été vite fait mal fait dans son avis de
paiement le gouvernement de nos
personnes touchées 30 jours pour
rembourser la lettre de Vincent des
biens a été produite le 19 juin il l'a
toutefois reçu le 9 juillet ça lui
laisse donc 10 jours pour payer je suis
tombé les nuque quand j'ai appris ça le
gouvernement met beaucoup de pression
alors que le gouvernement lui a pris
deux ans avant d'exiger le remboursement
de ces sommes là au moins quelques mois
si par exemple l'année c'était plus
raisonnable que 30 jours en plein été
les contribuables touchés doivent
contacter Service Canada pour établir
des modalités vraiment avec le
gouvernement les décisions seront donc
prises au cas par cas cela augmentera le
fardeau administratif de l'organisme qui
traite déjà les demandes de passeport
ici Marie-Pierre Mercier Radio-Canada
Québec